oh and there's plenty going on as it
relates to the nfl because the owners
met virtually today as they have been
doing since the pandemic began and we
have
some developments first of all the nfl
has approved a plan
for a 16 team post season in the event
that any games are lost due to
the pandemic so far through nine weeks
every game has been played but we see
the numbers going up we see the positive
cases going up among nfl teams players
placed on the covet 19 reserve list
multiple everyday staff members testing
positive it just feels like it's a
matter of time before the nfl needs an
18th week to the regular season there
won't be a 19th week
there would just be an 18th week and if
any games aren't made up within 18 weeks
then it's a 16 team post season just
like it was back in 1982 shireen when we
were seniors in high school i assume you
were a senior in 1982. true or false uh
that would be f i graduated in 83 so 82
i would have been a senior in the fall
that's correct that's right that's right
we we suffered through the strike i
remember the strike all those weeks
without football it ended up being a
nine game season and then they had a 16
team tournament so that's what would
happen and i'm fine with that
it doesn't completely take away the
unfairness of determining who gets in
and who doesn't based on winning
percentage right it just moves the
argument from
seven versus eight to eight versus nine
because if that ninth team would benefit
from playing an extra game and had
missed a game obviously or if the eighth
seed
only played 15 and maybe if they played
one more they would lose and they would
fall out of the chase there is that
potential for a sense of of inequity but
what the hell i'll take a couple of
extra postseason games in wild card
weekend make the one seeds play the
eight seeds maybe to be two teams from
the same division and the eighth seed
will create some chaos by knocking off
the one seed
absolutely mike it's a lot like what
baseball did right they expanded their
playoffs and
in the end we probably saw the best team
win the championship and and the best
team's going to come out of this thing
winning the championship but you talked
a lot about the covet cases going up
doesn't it just seem like we're on the
verge now of adding that extra week to
the regular season i mean it seems like
we're getting really really close to
games being postponed where they can't
be moved around and all of that with bye
weeks being gone it seems like we're
getting to that point pretty close
all it takes is one game at this point
and it will be an 18th week and it's
going to be a game that can't be made up
that week because there's no place else
to put the game if one of the teams has
already had its bye week unless you
expect the team to play twice within a
week and that's not going to happen so
that's where the 18th week would be and
you know there was the suggestion from
chris mad dog russo several weeks back i
was on his show and he said that the
18th week the extra week should go at
week 17 then week 17 goes to week 18 and
that's where
the season comes to a crescendo i don't
think they would do that i think they
are now wired to get the games in
asap
and even if it means
taking the risk because let's say let's
say here's what happens shireen
week 17
they finish the season with the
scheduled games week 18
there's two three four games left
they play those games week 18. they all
are completed
so there's no 16 team playoff
field
you're gonna have the one seeds go three
weeks between games three weeks and four
weeks if they decide having the one seed
locked up before week 17 to shut down
the starters like the ravens did last
year so that's the one
doughnut hole here
they need a week 18 but they still get
all the games in you're gonna have the
one seeds with at least three weeks off
between games potentially and
i am curious mike if those games don't
mean anything do they just throw that
week 18 out and go we're done with these
games we're moving on and another thing
we need to talk about is lost revenue
from from this season and the added
the added playoff games let's be
realistic would make up for a lot not a
lot but some of the lost revenue that
they have
for this season
well i agree with you and two things
first of all the union is not going to
want to ditch meaningless games because
if the players don't get paid unless the
games are played the players want the
games to be played because voila we get
paid secondly when you consider that
week 17 is always divisional games i
can't imagine
that there would be a ton of completely
and totally utterly meaningless games
except maybe between the third and
fourth place teams in the nfc east if
that's what it comes down to but it
seems like most of those games are going
to have at least one team
that that would be relevant of course
that's week 17 the postponed games we
don't know so never mind ignore that
forget forget everything i just said for
the last minute no i wondered where you
were going with that
so i wish i had or i wouldn't have gone
there but but
you know here's here's my point as the
season's coming to a conclusion it seems
like most of the games are relevant in
some way shape or form and i have a
feeling those extra games however many
they would be this is my effort at
trying to recover here one two three
games chances are it's going to be
relevant chances are there's going to be
some connection to whether or not a
team's three seed four seed division
winner or top wild card whatever the
case may be there's too many tentacles
between these teams that's what i was
trying to say and again as it relates to
the money the players want to get paid
so the players are going to say we don't
care if it doesn't matter we want ours
let's play the games so
we'll see we'll see and uh it's gonna be
interesting to see how it plays out but
that is just that thin narrow
possibility of
week 18
all games played
14 team playoffs proceed
one seeds potentially end up with three
weeks off which hey deal with it i mean
look good you get three weeks off fine
find a way to keep your guys in shape
and ready to go and they'll be
completely rested and healed and maybe
have a guy who was injured who's ready
to go who wouldn't have been so they're
not worried about those details they're
just worried about getting the games in
and then getting the playoffs in
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports